je vous parle aujourd'hui d'un
smartphone extrêmement intéressant
extrêmement intéressant non pas par le
produit en lui-même qui est pas mal on
est sur un smartphone d'entrée de gamme
mais n'est pas révolutionnaire il
n'apporte pas des usages complètement
dingue mais il est très intéressant par
la stratégie qui est décrite derrière
c'est ce smartphone là c'est le honor
20e un smartphone qui a été officialisé
au mois d'avril 2020 par au nord et qui
vient effectivement de sortir et que
j'ai juste ici dans la main et ce
smartphone il est vraiment très
intéressant parce qu'il montre un point
mais vraiment mais vraiment très très
très révélateur dans la stratégie de au
nord on pourrait se dire en parallèle la
stratégie de huawei puisque au nord et
vos ouailles font partie d'une groupe
c'est toute la problématique des
services google puisque ce smartphone
qui viennent sorti en avril 2020 à les
services google que vous expliquer
pourquoi que vous expliquer comment
puisque on pourrait dire ok je ne
comprends pas trop puisque effectivement
huawei honor n'ont pas l'autorisation
d'utiliser les services google comment
se fait-il qu'un nouveau smartphone
sorti en avril 2020 de au nord et les
services google et vous expliquer ça
vous allez voir c'est très simple avant
toute chose quand je tourne cette vidéo
on est toujours en période de
confinement et je vous avais demandé
pendant le confinement de m'envoyer vos
vidéos savoir comment ça se passe si
vous on va donc se visionner l la vidéo
du jour j'espère que tu as direct a
coûté 29 yb
- confinement je regarde tes vidéos et
les vidéos sur youtube et je fais mes
devoirs
voilà et puis monsieur message passé les
ennemis est très bien chez vous ne
sortez pas c'est pour le bien de la
france
merci pour cette vidéo je vous explique
maintenant ce qui se passe avec sonore
20e le honor 20e et le petit frère du
haut normand light sorti l'année
dernière ce qui se passe ici est ce que
fait au nord c'est tout simplement on
recycler des smartphones qui ont déjà la
licence google pour pouvoir
commercialiser un smartphone 9 en avril
2020 avec la licence google un
smartphone dans l'entrée de gamme ici
mais néanmoins un nouveau modèle avec la
licence google et c'est ça qui est
vraiment génial ou huawei et au nord ont
vraiment fait le choix de dire on ne
reviendra pas en arrière on intégrera
plus les services google dans nos
smartphones dans nos nouveaux
smartphones mais néanmoins là on est en
avril 2020 et on a un nouveau smartphone
pourrait sortir avec les syndics google
ce qui est révélateur là dedans c'est
que le choix fait par huawei et au nord
qui est un choix courageux de se dire
quoi qu'il se passe on ne travaillera
plus ricains et bien on voit que c'est
pas aussi simple que ça
huawei est au nord et là on parle de
honor dans ce cas-là bute sur un
problème c'est le fait de se passer
complètement de google et propose des
solutions alternatives vous êtes déjà
fait une vidéo pour vous parler de la
gallery vous expliquer comment récupérer
toutes vos applications
comment ça fonctionne et ce qui était
possible de faire mais malgré ça il y
aura forcément des consommateurs qui ne
feront pas se passer des services google
d'ailleurs vous dites moi est ce que
vous pourriez vous passer des services
google est ce que vous pourriez acheter
un smartphone de huawei ou deux au nord
sans les services google mark et moi ça
en bas en commentaire c'est compliqué à
quantifier le nombre de personnes qui
vont switcher ceux qui ne souhaiteront
pas mais ce qui est sûr c'est que c'est
un frein à l'expansion de au nord est de
huawei du coup pour continuer à vendre
des smartphones avec les indices google
des modèles qui ne sont pas trop anciens
et bien il faut quand même rajouter des
modèles au catalogue des modèles récents
avec les amis de google et pour ce faire
on fait un peu de réchauffer on reprend
une vie référence on la modifie un peu
et ça vous donne ce modèle là vous
prenez donc le au nord 20 live ou le
fond et dans une boîte et vous avez le
haut normand
alors ça c'est bien mais que vaut
réellement c aux normales le au nord
veut c'est avant tout quasiment la même
copie que le
20 light le même design on va retrouver
le triplé module photo à l'arrière on va
retrouver le capteur d'empreintes
digitales ici qui marche très bien qui
déverrouille extrêmement rapidement on
va retrouver un dégradé sur coise bleus
qui fonctionne bien
un grand écran va retrouver une encoche
goutte d'eau sur le dessus de la charge
en micro usb une prise jack
ce smartphone qui était entré milieu de
gamme et qui l'a clairement et
plafonnent d'entrée de gamme le honorera
lie quand il a été présenté était au
tarif de 299 euros
ce smartphone là les honneurs 20e et au
tarif de 179 euros et 90 centimes on a
donc plus de 100 euros d'écart au moment
où ses smartphones français alors bien
évidemment quand on s'en rend
smartphones avec sensiblement les mêmes
suspects un an après on se doute que le
prix sera beaucoup plus bas par rapport
aux autres produits du marché
néanmoins on aura dû faire d'autres
économies pour renier quand même sur le
prix et la première économie se fait au
niveau de son écran sur les honneurs
vallaeys vous aviez une dalle ip est ce
duel cdi si vous avez toujours du lcd
mais c'est pas de lit ps ici ses duels
tps
on est ici exactement la même taille
d'écran c'est une dalle de 6,21 pouces
full hd + 2340 un 1080 pixels à 415
pixels par pouce ratio 19 points 5/9
certificat lutter contre la lumière
bleue moi ce que je vous conseille
vraiment ici de venir dans les
paramètres vous allez dans affichage
vous allez dans mots des températures de
couleur et vous êtes par défaut en
couleurs vives
je trouve ça cria je vous l'avais déjà
dit sur le nord 20,5 mais c'est
exactement la même chose mettez vous en
normal les couleurs sont un petit peu
violine vous venez ensuite leur
rapprocher du jeune et là je crois qu'on
a vraiment le meilleur résultat pour la
partie audio c'est exactement la même
chose vous avez un petit haut parleur
mono qui situent juste là vous avez une
prise jack
on est choqué mais john key s'est
toujours très rapidement et même qu'il y
ait des sceaux et bien sûr sa ceinture
quand même la qualité pas extraordinaire
que je vous conseille là dessus c'est
d'utiliser la prise jack
la qualité va être un peu amélioré le
spect va s'élargir un petit peu on
restera quand même beaucoup centré son
médium on ne va donc pas venir acheter
ce smartphone pour l'expérience
multimédia
mais si vous voulez un smartphone de
2020 bien fabriquer de chez au nord avec
le plextor et bien lieu aux normes offre
à la sphère côté performances c'est
exactement la même chose sur le haut
norvins lite vous aviez un kirin 710 ici
vous avez un kirin 710 f
il n'y a pas de différence en termes de
performances entre le 710 et le 710 f
par contre j'ai une différence c'est
qu'à voir vous aviez
4 gigas de ram 128 gb de stockage
extensible jusqu'à 512 grâce à une carte
microsd
et si vous avez toujours 4 gigas de ram
mais vous avez 64 giga de stockage
il ya quand même une différence surtout
quand on sait que les os prendre la
place donc au nord a fait aussi cette
modification pour venir gagner sur le
tarif
la batterie est exactement la même trois
mille quatre cent millions perreard on
pourra garder une journée à une journée
et demie en fonction de vos usages
lohouès celle même le m8 9.1 basé sur un
android neuf avec comme je le disais le
plextor qui vous permettra d'avoir
toutes les applications que vous
souhaitez avoir sans absolument aucune
restriction
la partie photo est quasiment la même
vous avez un capteur principal de 24
mégapixels couvre f 1.8 c'est la même
chose vous avez un ultra grand-angle de
8 mégapixels bref de points 4 avec un
champ de vision de 120 degrés c'est la
même chose et vous avez une caméra de 2
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.4 qui est là
pour moi de portraits cas pour les faits
évoqués on a exactement la même
configuration à l'arrière que sur l'eau
normale ait la différence va situé sur
la face avant puisque ici vous n'avez
pas une caméra de 30 2 mégapixels mais
une caméra de 8 mégapixels qui ouvre à f
2.0
je vous montre les photos prises avec le
honor 20e vous allez voir résultats il
pas complètement dingue ça fera la faire
pour quelques photos quelques souvenirs
que vous n'allez pas avoir la meilleure
qualité une fois de plus on est sur un
smartphone qui coûte un petit peu moins
de 180 euros crise avec le capteur
principal le rendu est somme toute assez
correct on n'a pas trop lui en demander
dès qu'on passe sur l'ultra grand temps
que la qualité est moindre et déformant
beaucoup moins précis et dès qu'on se
rapproche vous en douterez on va venir
récupérer beaucoup de bruit pour être
très transparent vous faites des photos
en foin
sans chercher un zoom et 100 m du très
grand-angle et c'est là vous aurez une
meilleur rendu et qui fera vraiment la
faire pour quelques partage sur les
réseaux sociaux et pour quelques
souvenirs
dès que vous passez sur l'ultra grand
pas envoyer la du mal à faire le point
il est déformant
coût moins précis quelle est la
principale on passe sur l'ut racontant
que c'est moins bon on se rapproche on a
récupéré ici un petit peu de bruit voyez
sur les côtés et des blues ou mais
davantage suite la qualité n'est plus à
du tout tamera principal est ultra
grand-angle on se rapproche beaucoup
trop c'est pas terrible ça c'est les
photos que j'ai prises en conditions de
faible luminosité il n'y avait aucune
lumière dans la pièce si ce n'est à
travers les volets fermés s'ébruiter
c'est pas anormal on est sur un
smartphone qui coûte une fois de plus
180 euros et ça il faut le préciser
j'ai tenté à différents endroits avec
différentes luminosité voilà on s'attend
pas à voir des merveilles
la caméra de cellfish fait le boulot
sans être vraiment extraordinaire il ne
cherchait pas utiliser le mode portrait
même si vous avez une caméra de 2
mégapixels c'est vraiment pas terrible
le détourage au niveau des doigts se
fait vraiment hasardeusement on ne l'a
pas ici la qualité n'est pas belle mais
une fois de plus ce smartphone coûte 180
euros ça il faut le savoir avec son
heureux que vous avez une double nano
simon alors une à nothing plus une carte
micro sd comme vous le disait jusqu'à
512 giga de stockage vous avez
absolument aucune certification de
résistance à l'eau et à la poussière
si vous êtes dehors et qu'il pleut vous
inquiétez pas il va pas se mettre à flot
mais tout ira bien
il a du nfc bon c'est un smartphone que
je trouve plutôt pas mal pour l'entrée
de gamme à 179 euros 90 ça fonctionne
il est un peu moins spectacle que choses
près que ce qu'on avait sur le au nord
20 light mais surtout est ce que ça
montre et ce qui est vraiment très très
intéressant c'est que malgré la
stratégie de au nord ouest se dire on
s'émancipe complètement google est bien
pour l'instant
ils ont encore un peu besoin sur
certains modèles pour réussir à les
vendre sans que le consommateur se pose
la question du pl ace store ou de la
galerie sans que le consommateur bob se
positionner et sans qu'elle risque de
louper des ventes avec ce smartphone là
ils savent que la question ne se posera
donc pas sur le playsport ou sans la
galerie et la galerie je vous le dis moi
je trouve ça intéressant tout ça
courageux et ça apporte une offre
alternative et la concurrence est
toujours bonne pour le consommateur
d'eau trouve ça bien que huawei effet
soit pour l'instant c'est pas encore
complètement parfait puisqu'il reste
encore pas mal d'applications emmené au
catalogue mais malgré tout je trouve que
huawei et au nord ont fait un choix
intéressant qui atteint mira vraiment
dans le sens du consommateur
voilà ce que je pense aujourd'hui son
offre un voeu si vous voulez un
smartphone d'entrée de gamme que vous
voulez payer pas trop cher il
intéressant maintenant ce qui peut aussi
être difficile pour lui c'est de se
battre face à des concurrents comme
xiaomi qui ont des modèles
efforts à des tarifs vraiment cassé a
vous de me dire vous maintenant ce que
vous en pensez comment vous trouvez
sonore 20e est ce que vous pourriez
acheter est ce que vous avez le
haut-normand light est ce que vous
l'avez eue
et est-ce que celui là pourrait vous
faire l'oeil et qu'est ce que vous
pensez de toute cette histoire vous
renvoyer au nord abyale replay storm
arkema tout ça on va en commentaires en
tout cas s'il vous intéresse
eh bien il ya une promo qui est
disponible pour l'instant
jusqu'au 11 mai c'est à dire ça nous
laisse très peu de jours entre moment où
je sens la vidéo et le 11 mai sur le
site de honor vous avez un lien dans la
description vous pouvez l'acheter au
taquet à 260 1990 et au nord vous offre
des écouteurs bluetooth qui coûte quand
même quasiment 70 euros donc ça peut
être bien si pour que vous voulez des
écouteurs parce que oui bien évidemment
vous pouvez utiliser des écouteurs
bluetooth sans aucun problème ça sera
d'ailleurs bien meilleure en termes
d'expérience qu'écouter des séries des
films de la musique au travers du haut
parleur qui globalement n'est pas
extraordinaire
a vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez
en bas en commentaire quant à nous on se
retrouve demain pour continuer à parler
peut-être les faisant venir plein de
bisous plein d'amour et à demain chacun
[Musique]